happy Tuesday reject nation it's Greg
Alba here I'm John Humphrey man bonds
Manzanar you gonna name myself after a
gun when you got a man gone Macklemore
he's great rapper
we're gonna watch today from screen
junkies honest trailers one of my
all-time favorite shows I haven't seen
this show in a few years but I actually
watched a couple episodes like a month
ago just for fun Batman the Animated
Series
I'm very side no idea they were working
on this I'm very excited for it screen
junkies I'm actually going back there on
the 29th for movie fights Joestar who
hates reactions have been doing this I
hate trailer reaction videos I think
they're really faking me up and said you
want to come back on Ben on movie fights
three times this year of one two out of
three let's see if I can do three out of
four 29th of November so keep a lookout
for that one guys but before we hop into
this I wanted to say a big thank you to
everyone who's been following us at our
patreon page we've been posting so much
over there the main things that we do
our weekly Q&A s and we also do TV show
reactions for many of shows that
includes anime Academy a-- Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and attack on
Titan almost at season three one more
episode ago and then of course we do
some live action as like Riverdale
Gotham Batman and supernatural and John
does a lot of music video coverage we
have some shows that already complete
and we didn't post a bunch of stuff over
there so go check out our patreon page
to see if we want to become a patron
Jack today enough BS promoting movie
fights and patreon pages mmmm move on to
the BM good bull man-bat [ __ ] oh this is
short it's only seven minutes oh good
before he was swole a [ __ ] he was
existentially depressed and before he
was a cartoon nearly became without he
was a swole existentially depressed to a
time when popcorn superhero animation
still ruled excess minutes offline
oh yeah and spent some time in Kevin
Conroy is iconic Bruce Wayne and
industrialists with the money of Tony
Stark and the fashion said food but
would not balls the world's greatest
detective who's also the world's
greatest ninja o greatest fathers I've
accessed Gotham's electrical mainframe
there's another computer uplink to this
one I'm tracing the link now greatest
magician we've got the makings of a
great magician ventriloquist when I
studied with Zatara the magician he
taught me about ventriloquism
Wow this madman has a lot for dance
[Applause]
[Music]
ah manscape isn't crusading solo he gets
a whole K full of allies like Alfred
Pennyworth Butler a Batman a king of
sick Birds
Clayface is losing his integrity a
college kid whose relationship with bats
is super creepy after you've seen The
Killing Joke that's a great move 100% me
men and Commissioner Gordon terrible the
second servant tormented by a
billionaire psychopath determined to
drive him insane proving at the Grand
Park our right a city trapped somewhere
between 1932 and 1392 a town where the
crime is Oaks the nights are long and
the people are rectangles
it's a city under siege in the best
rogues gallery in animation history Oh
in Turin character to fighting
portrayals of toupees mr. freeze
Harley Quinn I really am oh yeah the
best Joker ever yeah I said it
[Laughter]
that's an address work of animals and
bet jeez bad man maybe you should stick
to something less threatening like a
penguin
[Music]
so why did the bat signal and revisit
the highs height
[Music]
that bad kind of surfers monster I
believe she would disagree of the
darkest adaptation of Batman ever made a
little in the darkest because they drew
it on black paper that wasn't afraid to
hit kids with complex philosophy then
break it up with a guy keeping a
werewolf in the bass fight you're
looking for try starting CDC that's only
what a definitive portrait of a beloved
character that balances multiple tones
across dozens of hours that can only
happen with a perfect community plans at
the perfect time the cultural zeitgeist
is that so hard
listen up scum wad here's how it works
entering
as Professor Craig lost his appetite
yeah he's back there you just terrible
marks my chair yeah
[Music]
maniacal laughter rods
rich Rev al Ghul that nerds obeys gas
attacks
[Music]
Wow
you recall fair few gas attacks some
espouse idiots voting yeah
and everything you wanted top suited you
lunatic
we're sitting on a powder tank men times
up Jim nope the other one that's the
ones you this Batman Forever
yeah okay we need to talk about the
introvert sack has anyone else noticed
that the crooks are just two guys who
happen to be walking past the bank at
night then when the entrance explodes
they run away like any sane person would
do they don't even have any loot on him
sure fine they pull guns on Batman but
for all they know he's a psycho going
around blowing up banks and Batman
doesn't know who did it either he had to
drive there but does that stop him from
beating the crap out of him and leave
him for the cops
without any evidence to convict him on
this is why [ __ ] Alandise are a bad
idea you guys five times into a mirror
ah spooky scary skeletons and shivers
down my spine who will survive and what
will be left of their extant sup eyes
bones thank we is so many snacks same
time Aeon Flux
I once wrote a batman poem based off of
on the dark night that's right out of
your sight into the night you need to
put some like Tom Waits style like weird
carnival music underneath it and just
you know release it as your first so I
think it works better as spoken-word
know exactly saying do the spoken words
overtop some kind of musical I have a
license to vengeance to aid in your
sentence
oh yeah thought so got some of it in my
noggin oh yeah dude with that that
famous Batman quote my inventions I am
the knight Batman add your own stamp but
a penguin belongs in the water I'll put
you away I'll chase the Grace and red
day evil in the to face
that was sad I made that like years ago
this is the early days man now you got
to go back write a new Batman app
updated to incorporate all the new
Batman stuff you've taken in since then
it's gonna be great my favorite bit
about this honest trailer was the Jim
Gordon part yeah never heard of that
joke he's an old man you're gonna give
this guy a heart attack one day
just stop sneaking up on him for no real
reason and using so many like you know
fragments of scenes and out of context
moment it's like you do realize how the
sinister Batman is often drawn in the
show yeah it always does look like he is
actually trying to creep up oh I gotta
admire them whenever they do something
like this because I'm like this must
have taken granted you know I'm sure
that this data as opposed to like the
Doctor Who ones I'm sure the staff had a
bit more of like a background knowledge
already but yeah just to go through and
compile well I'm still challenging I
think for an honest trailer like this
with strangers does you gotta make sure
you find this right blend cuz it's like
yeah you got to make fun of it you got
to point out the goofy things about it
and all the tropes yeah but you also got
to point out stuff of why it's cool and
I think they did a great job at
balancing both sides of showing like
this really is the darkest version of
Batman like the episode I watched a
month ago or something was the one where
the Mad Hatter I'm kind of giving away
the twist if you haven't seen the
episode the Mad Hatter he kidnaps Batman
and we don't know this till the very end
but he's in this like alternate world
where someone else's Batman and he's
just Bruce Wayne his parents have been
around but it's still like he was silver
remembers being Batman oh so he's really
confused about the world is in is he
just been delusional and it's a really
interesting psychological exploration of
what if Bruce Wayne had just been beat
you know Bruce Wayne and is really
boring life yeah I mean this show tended
to go a bit quite night
marish honestly my main incentive to get
the DC streaming service is to get this
but I think like I said hey I think they
just release it on blu-ray where it's
like upgraded quality of course and I
hear it's pretty much night and day oh
how much better looks I own all the
seasons on DVD but I've heard that the
quality they remastered is amazing yeah
I don't need like the sharpest clarity
for a lot of things but I do feel like
hand-drawn animation actually looks
amazing when they restore it and all
that stuff like because the art in this
show is also really beautiful in yeah
like it is super dark and this is kind
of where the bedrock of things like
Gotham City come from in my mind I wish
they talked about mask of the phantasm
even though I know that came out a year
into the anime series even if you
haven't seen the animated series and you
want to see if it's something for you I
think the mask of the phantasm movie is
something you should totally check out
if you're looking if you haven't seen
the show because there's still plenty of
people who haven't seen this animated
series but to me it's the best animated
series of all time we we had a question
one of our Q&A is on patreon was about
what show do I think from the 90s could
be revived and still work that's only
one show from my childhood I think could
be brought back would it be [ __ ]
weird and you can continue it make it
work keep the fans happy there's only
one chef there's only one show once you
friends now my answer with Batman the
Animated Series each episode does feel
like a graphic novel with continuations
in them but it wasn't as hyper
serialized as most shows are today even
though it's still is to realize you know
like how epic voice guy john bailey
points out here and a lot of people
still consider mark Hamill's the Joker
the best version he can still play it he
still sometimes does between the between
the game selling joke movie yeah and
Kevin Conroy is like you what's to stop
them from bringing it back and having
the same voice actors come back I mean
this show berth Harley Quinn it did yeah
which and she's bigger than ever now not
to get her oh yeah oh yeah like yeah
we're doing the whole franchise now
Oliver yeah whole bunch of Harley Quinn
joints yeah
that direct inspiration it comes from
the show yeah I don't think it's a
perfect series there's aspects of it
that do feel dated it wasn't really
rather mature cartoon and that's why I
think it's honest show does it so well
because they point out how sometimes it
was a wacky cartoon yeah and there are
other times where it was a really deep
matura cartoon yeah like this show and a
number of others came around at a
fascinating time for you know
programming aimed at kids because yeah
you would get kind of a weird
oscillation between really whimsical
stuff and then stuff that is yes
surprisingly either intense or scary or
just mature thematically I mean this
show exemplifies that as well I mean I
I'm almost curious to go back and think
oh I was allowed to watch this and I was
like you know eight years old yeah
there's just like gods like just people
unloading machine guns like all over
there at the time I don't think I would
have thought about but now you know
can't go over everything the show covers
or introduces to the world they did
introduce my favorite like Nightwing is
my favorite comic-book character the
like in terms of comics I've actually
read Nightwing is my favorite and
Nightwing does appear I think in the
very last season of this show but my
favorite Robin is Tim Drake and this
show introduced me to who Tim Drake
it was Oh Dan before I ever read of him
in any comic book this shows introduced
me to a hell of a lot and it is the
defining one and I can't argue anyone
who thinks this is the best Batman or
the best Joker by any stretch you know
yeah quite honestly you could probably
just get them both to do it in a
live-action setting and it would
probably work Kevin Conroy bulk up and
then you know Mark Hamill has to do is
put on some crazy makeup you know one
thing that's honest trailer also really
pointed out in such a clever way it did
everything that we want DC to do now
they have a really great joke here about
like that the run-on sentence said do is
be the perfect combination of tones with
like I didn't even expand over to this
period of time but also just its opening
line about like before he was full
before he's impress and as I am doing
this I'm seeing that as the top of the
description box
or even a cartoon wall deprived art they
did all the things that we kind of joke
about or whatever but they did all in
one and it was seamless so yeah I mean
Batman's Batman Batman but you know this
is arguably a definitive absolutely
riddle me this riddle me that your clue
sorry miss you must mistake me for a
dingbat all right well thanks screen
junkies I'll see you guys on the
twenty-ninth movie fights yay I love
prepping for movie fights yeah the day
before is always a smooth smooth evening
no stress and no research and no
prepping just chilling just chilling
smoking unrelated movies yeah no I know
everything already and I'm relying
purely on instinct on this one I'm not
helping you no no Johnny before we wrap
this up I wanted to give a patron in the
day shout-out to a man named Daniel
Gallagher
Daniel Gallagher is a man all the way
from Scotland 23 year old recently we've
been talking like he's one of the few
people I talked with about better call
Saul he loves that show I am slowly
making my way through that series and
he's someone who's always encouraged me
to watch it while I am encouraging him
to continue my favorite show of all time
friends so we have a really good rapport
a really good back and forth you know
it's in this Halloween we were talking
recently he was also telling me about
how he's been catching up on some movies
some great horror movies that I love
Cape Fear The Shining the original
psycho so Daniel I'm glad you're doing
well hope you're having a happy happy
Halloween and Scotland hopefully you're
all dressed up as Americans as your
costumes because that's the real thing
you want to do yeah we're in jeans and
button-down plaids all right guys well
you can subscribe with the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon TV show reactions Q&A is a
lot of goodies yay
it's hard to block the strength of Kruk
but I've been trained I've obtained
skills that cannot be explained